well it took just a few hours maybe for
the latest Trump Republican plan the
straight-up repeal of the Affordable
Care Act and worry about replacing it
later
to be dead and done we've seen this
growing number of failed attempts to
pass a replacement to Obamacare so knit
the sort of new thing has been Trump and
some Republicans thought hey here's an
idea let's just repeal Obamacare and
then figure out a replacement at some
later point in time Donald Trump has
been tweeting about this for some time
including over the last couple of days
saying first on Twitter Republicans
should just repeal failing Obamacare now
and work on a new health care plan that
will start from a clean slate Dems will
join in later tweeting as I have always
said let Obamacare fail and then come
together and do a great health care plan
stay tuned now of course that would have
been a train wreck it would have caused
about 32 million people to end up
without insurance instead of the 22 to
23 million that we were estimated by the
CBO to end up without insurance if the
eighth AHCA had passed and it took again
just a matter of hours before we learned
yesterday that that was also a total
non-starter three female Republican
senators immediately said yet no we're
not voting on just a repeal without a
replacement Susan Collins Shelley Moore
Capito who by the way follows the david
pakman show on twitter and : were
wondering pat and lisa murkowski all
said yeah we're just we're not doing
that and of course with 52 Republicans
in the Senate when three people say
we're not voting for it you can't do it
and Rob Portman from Ohio had also been
hinting that he would oppose a
straight-up Obamacare repeal moot since
three Republicans already said no dice
we heard from senator Orrin Hatch a
Republican from Utah who said quote it's
a much tougher process than people
thought it was how many times are
Republicans going to use that excuse is
every Republican surprised at how
difficult it is to repeal and replace
something as major as the Affordable
Care Act
while taking care not to end up with
millions more people without insurance
how are they so surprised at the
difficulty of this well it shouldn't be
surprising especially because many of
these Republicans constituents rely on
the Medicaid expansion too so you know
their voters may not realize that
they're dependent on that now but if you
take that away from them they certainly
would find out in both their
representatives out of office and so the
numbers never really added up and I
think Democrats have to make this a
cornerstone of their campaigns and
twenty-eighth they do and that's why I
think this is a good exercise for
Republicans to have to go through it's
really easy to talk bad as Donald Trump
likes to say about Obamacare when
Obama's in office and there's no chance
that any of your bogus house repeal
votes are actually going to lead to any
change now you have to govern in the
majority with a friendly White House you
have to think about as Pat is saying how
many of your constituents will end up
without care this is not obstruction
from Democrats it's Republican failure
they have the white house they've got a
majority in the house they've got a
majority in the Senate they've had seven
years this is on them even though Trump
is already trying to do the spin where
it's Democratic obstruction or it's
let's just let Obamacare fail and it'll
be on them Donald Trump earlier today or
maybe yesterday the clip I saw Trump
saying hey this is just not on me he's
the guy who campaigned on only I can fix
it and now he's saying I've got nothing
to do with any of this and they they
will soon move too if they can't just
repeal Obamacare let it collapse and the
truth is it will be a very slow collapse
I mean yeah premiums are going up for
Obamacare plans but they're going up for
all plans and slightly more slowly for
Obama care plans and yes some people
still can't afford care but that's been
going on for a long time and Obamacare
is pretty conservative so it's no
surprise that Obamacare didn't fix the
issue where now everybody can afford or
get care short of HR 676 which is the
Medicare for all of Medicaid Medicare
expansion proposal from Democrats in
January what is the option I don't know
maybe Republicans could work with
Democrats to fix some of the problems
with the Affordable Care Act and make
everybody's lives better I genuinely
don't
no but yet another proposal I guess what
we're calling Plan C dead within hours
Pat I mean it seems as if the
Republicans have lost twice when it
comes to this health care battle since
they've held all three branches of
government and who knows I don't think
you know anyone's going to be crawling
back to them to try to find a solution
to the Affordable Care Act because it's
not failing as Trump is suggesting but
they'll be back they'll try this again
in a few months we'll see what the next
configuration is plan D I guess is what
it'll be called the video you just
watched was made possible by support
from you please go to patreon.com slash
david pakman show you can make a pledge
of as little as $1 per month and every
dollar helps to support the work that
we're doing particularly in light of the
YouTube ad boycott which has been really
bad